thank you
hey everybody and welcome to a
correctional wild ride with Stevo this
episode is killer we've got James Allen
Jr who was on death row for years three
years then he got his sentence commuted
to life in prison without the
possibility of parole then he got that
sentence commuted to life with the
possibility of parole so he can speak to
what it was like to be on death row what
it was like to be in regular prison
general population and what it's like to
be to be free I mean this is the wildest
of wild rides man wow is this epic let's
get into it if uh if you want any of
that okay
I got more lives than the cat so why
would I do liquid death
it's a company that I really believe in
I'm an ambassador of it okay
the idea is death to plastic is it
actually water it's still water from the
house okay ladies and gentlemen former
death row inmate James Allen Jr good to
meet you you too Stevo all right so this
is interesting and it came about when I
recently went on quite a rant about the
death penalty how it's uh incredibly
expensive with all the appeals that you
got to go through to execute Somebody by
the time you've executed a prisoner
you've spent I thought it was 10 times
the amount that it would cost to keep
them alive for the rest of their natural
life but I've learned it's more like two
to three times
still making it pretty dumb and I've got
all kinds of thoughts about the death
penalty just being stupid and we threw
out the idea wouldn't it be cool to
interview a death row inmate and we got
all kinds of responses and somebody said
what do you think about a guy who was on
death row then got his well you you tell
us what's the your career with uh
correctional facilities
well let me just say I'm uh
ecstatic being here today and it's good
to meet the famous Stevo well thank you
jackass so
um you know mine is a unique experience
um growing up here in Nevada and in Las
Vegas
um
in one of the poorest areas of the of
the town and you know I had a father and
a mother but uh like most marriages
theirs didn't last so now I'm stuck with
a single mother and she's trying to
raise two boys that are
gun hoe you know so uh she was a
Christian and she drugged us to church
and made us sing in the choir and you
know my mother was a singer and she's
still living
um
she's um
she's a big part of the reason why I'm
uh I'm here today and my freedom exists
um my mom is a pioneer
she uh
struggled in the 70s and she also did a
little time for murder so you can see
where her son
grows up and end up on death row for
murder so but hers were was a case of uh
domestic violence and she ended up with
a second degree type of deal and she did
a little probation but anyway
growing up here on the streets of Las
Vegas wow you know I can remember the
errors of the Moulin Rouge he has a
little 12 13 year old kid trying to get
up in there did you find yourself in
jail or prison before the murder well
you know I was my juvenile life was
um
pretty normal you know fights here and
there curfew she would have to come down
and get me but as I got older and my
fascination with guns and you know being
associated with gains and of that nature
and you know The Pimps and the hustlers
these are my type of people man you know
so and that's right the murderer was
when you were 17 yes
um I was pretty good at what they call
cat walking it had an older guy older OG
a guy from the neighborhood and he was
pretty good at what he does okay I don't
know what catwalking is well cat walking
is like
um
you're knocking on you're going to a
strange neighborhood and it's not a
burglary because you're hoping to catch
someone there so you can do the robbery
and the burglary you know it's like a
two two in one catch you know so that
sounds more like a home invasion yes
that's right home invasion now yes
that's what they're that's a that's a
serious crap and back well back then
they looked at it as a real serious
crime and like I said I was the I was
the first one to receive the death
sentence when that law came in effect in
Nevada
okay so so your your murder happened
during a home invasion is that yes yes
it was a home invasion uh me and the
older guy
um we went and I was strapped with a gun
and uh the homeowner was there and
and he suddenly woke up and he heard
noise he grabbed his gun and when he
came around the corner with his gun
I didn't give him a chance you know I
fired and uh I fired two shots and lo
and behold in the darkness I mean pure
black darkness this guy got hit right
between the eyes and you know that
didn't hit me until later on in you know
my adult year as a as a kid you know
that didn't really ring out to me how
uh one shot could take a person's life
when you know I just really just shot
you know so but anyway yo that landed me
a first degree murder uh with burglary
right I got to believe that with the
home invasion happening uh at the time
that that's even an aggravated first
degree murder if that if that's a thing
yeah well they never they never put
anything on the table but capital
offense right for murder so it was
either going to be life without or the
death penalty right okay
um I'm really interested because I pay
attention to a lot of True Crime stuff
and I I see all the time that
murderers will do anything to avoid the
death penalty they'll take that plea
bargain just to get death penalty off
the table right was that an option for
you at the time well I had a couple
um a couple of crafty attorneys and they
were state appointed attorneys so they
kind of laid the law down you're young
this D.A is really seeking this death
sentence you know he's pushing to be
Governor one day and you know Lord
Behold a guy becomes Governor but anyway
um it's like he said you're either gonna
except
the rest of your life in prison
or this state is going to try and
execute you and he goes
executing you they may not do it's it's
it's it's very expensive James and
this is a tourism type of town and they
don't want to be known for executing a
teenager or a youngster you know wow he
goes uh I'm gonna fight like hell
but
um it's on the table life without
and my mom by her doing time before she
no
even though I know my son did this but
no not life without in prison so we'll
take our chances in trial
got it and that's how I ended up in
trial
and I went in front of a like a senior
citizen jury you know I'm looking like
all of these old people are my my peers
you know and it was you know uh it was
so
um dramatic in the courtroom uh shouting
crying you know the victim's family over
here and you got their side of it and
I'm understanding that you know uh then
you got my side of the family and I mean
my mom was a soldier she she walked
around that County Jail at night after
she come and visit me she would
literally walk around the county jail
and get people to walk with her
you know to free James Allen they're
going to give my son a death sentence so
when he went to trial were you uh did
you plead not guilty and you were trying
to get acquitted well I'll tell you what
I was interrogated for like 16 almost 17
hours by two two detectives because they
really wanted my co-defendant you know
he was the bigger fish
I'm facing charges of of murder but they
wanted him they've been looking for this
you know this guy's a seasonal vet he's
a career criminal you know he's he stung
for big money in this town and so we all
kind of looked up to this guy as being
the OG of the neighborhood you know so
uh they interrogated me like six 16
hours and they're they're constantly
telling me you're gonna get the death
penalty man you better we know this
guy's your co-defendant you know we know
he's and I wouldn't give him up you know
I wouldn't give them a name card in the
street at time but I tell you what
they got my mom on the phone yes Dakota
the streets off you don't tell you know
snitch they just get snitches but uh so
they called my mom and she's on the
phone and it's like a conference call
and she goes well I'll tell you what
uh I know my son is guilty
but he's not guilty as the guy you guys
are looking for
see mom is trying to sweat you know
she's really trying to get this she
knows what's ahead of me and so I make a
confession
well I was there I orchestrated the
whole plot you know uh I chose the house
yeah yeah I did the Fatal shot yeah
everything
and the detectives go they wasn't happy
with that
you know they wanted the co-defendant
may you rest in peace he's dead now but
you know I mean I even talked about him
in the book but
um
what an experience man and I tell you
what
after all that I've been through
I understand the death penalty
was it for guys like me a young kid you
know ambition uh ambition out the roof
uh just who is it for them
it's for the guy that gives up
that look at you me and everyone and say
I don't care about you
I don't care if you die today and I
don't care if it's by these hands
that's who it's for
okay
um I mean where do you put those type of
people that think like that they I mean
is there such a thing as uh verse on one
psychology where you can really go in
and a person's belief you can change
their belief in humanity all right now
I'm not doubting or suggesting that
there are not
people who just should never be allowed
into society ever again and I also
recognize that there's a problem with uh
life in prison not meaning life in
prison I mean here we're we're talking
to the guy who is on death row got his
sentence commuted to life and that is
now walking the streets well you know
what Stevo I think I'm the ultimate
guinea pig
I was a test
you know I literally grew up in prison
evidently I mean
so at the trial you you pled not guilty
after they had this confession 16 hours
yeah so the trial probably didn't last
too long
not too much deliberating five hours
hours of a trial or five hours of
deliberation
the whole thing
the jail was ready to erupt because you
know uh I was in jail for over a year
you know so and before that before the
conviction okay yeah and so you're
meeting all types of people
uh you know you're young and they had
you in adult jail waiting for trial oh
yes they had me down where it was like
eight of us in a secured area and we
were all facing the death penalty some
of these guys one guy was his name was
Billy Henson
and he was considered a serial killer
real nice guy though and he was the only
guy who had a guitar that I ever seen
with a hollow guitar in in in jail but
they catered to this guy and you know
and he was he had a real Charming
personality did he get the death penalty
no
the serial killer did not get Joe Joe
Koza another one he killed the taxi
driver and the um the passenger did he
get the death penalty no
he's got I was the only one Tony I can
just name guys whose trial was lined up
right just right after mine and I was
the only one to get the death feeling
um well maybe those other guys took the
plea to get the death penalty off the
table maybe they didn't do the truth
okay yeah you know a couple of them got
overflowed to another courtroom and but
it was just uh kind of different that I
received the death sentence and I was
the youngest one because right a couple
of these guys were career criminals I
wonder if you're not snitching had
anything to do with that
you know uh I went for heart
and I didn't you know I had some OG's to
get to me early they said don't get all
tatted up don't get a sleeve they don't
need you know
it's gonna be hard dude so one day you
may have a chance of going on they gave
you life without you may go home one day
laws are changing you know so I kept
myself kind of clean-cut and you know
but
um
back to that question with the guys
on death row that deserve it you know
when your neighbor is a dude that just
killed a girl
you know a little 12 year old girl
Slither throat yeah you know
you know this caffeinated her body and
just burnt parts of her you know put in
a shallow grave and you know this is my
neighbor so it was hard for me to come
out
doing a wreck period on death row and
not try to kill this guy under a wreck
period okay Recreation period right
right right no and there was ways back
in the day death row wasn't very secure
like it is up in Ely Nevada you know
right back in Carson City the old death
row and I was allowed to go back there a
year ago and I it was like today into
the chamber no I went back on death this
prison is is closed and the arts society
and the Nevada prison Society getting
ready to do a uh tour like so they
invited me back and I went through and
took a cameraman and finally went in the
chamber you know this is supposed to be
my I got pictures in my phone wow can I
can I ask when they read the verdict you
know death
what goes through your head I mean are
you just
so scared that you're blacking out and
you're like well I'll tell you what
um
you know
as at a young age I knew that I was
different you know I wasn't no follower
you know you couldn't convince me to do
nothing at a young age so
when
I took on a leadership
role while I was in jail with the other
youngsters you know uh every chance I've
been to Law Library talking to him and
hey dude we destined for prison you know
we going we just don't know what our
faith is but um
when they read that verdict
my mother I heard a whaling sound it was
my mom and I never heard her scream like
that and it went through me and I looked
around and these cameras was in the
courtroom and you know I was the
youngest
to receive that death sentence at that
time and it was big news you know like
say the true magazine the detectives I
was in all that series but it hit me
um
it finally hit me when they chained me
up
you know it wasn't a regular put your
hands behind your back now it's my
ankles from my ankle to my waist from my
waist to here wow and I'm sitting in the
back of this uh Cessna plane by myself
with uh three other people or two guards
and a pilot and they go well kid you're
in the safest part of the plane and I've
never been in a plane before but I was
all the way back in the tail and they
said well
this won't be your death sentence
because if we go down they're trying to
build some humor in me or something get
me to laugh or something you know but uh
at that moment it hit me that the
seriousness that
okay
I'm going to my uh demise this is it
the state is going to take care of my
death you know
um did you know how long it was going to
happen in or the time period Well the
attorney was explaining to me uh he said
we get an automatic appeal James uh it's
a shame that your first execution date
is uh
uh two days before your 20th birthday
yeah and he said I go wow I won't make
21. and he goes well yeah you're going
to get a stiff execution and if that
fails then we're going to file to the
governor we're going to file to the
Supreme Court you know we're gonna just
it's gonna be delayed you'll be old man
sitting up here right because Nevada is
not going to do it he said but my goal
is to get you off
right let you live a life in prison you
know I don't think they ever let you out
James and that attorney
when he watched me come home after 28
years
he was standing there
man where would he be without that
lawyer and as a small business owner
where would I be without ship station
that's right man if you want to kill it
in today's world you gotta have an
e-commerce business going off and if
you're gonna have that then you have to
have ship station because with every
order you need to ship it out and ship
station gives you discounted prices for
like all of your different carriers hell
you get up to 88 off of USPS that's the
United States Postal Service and ups and
if you want to get an even better deal
then go to
shipstation.com and use the promo code
Stevo for two months of a free trial I
mean you can't go wrong plus this is how
we ship everything out of my Stevo
online store it's the Savior for my
business like James Allen Junior's
lawyer ship station is always on my side
and they can be on your side if you go
to
shipstation.com and use the promo code
Stevo I bid you well to kill it with
e-commerce now let's get back to it
wow I'm afraid creaming attorney at law
he's still attorney yeah I'm his biggest
case man uh he's in the book
and the book is called not my chair
that I picked not my chair because
at that time in the chamber is two
chairs
and you know it's gas you know I'll
lethal injection at that time you know
they had a bucket under the chair and
they had to pellet it rolls down and it
hits the gas and you know wow you're
gonna die off your your bomb making your
so one of the chairs
is missing
and I found out later where the chairs
at the chairs at the Mob Museum
when I came home from prison they found
out my story gave me a job at the Mob
Museum next to this chair is like being
reunited with my demise wait a minute
this is the chair that they were
supposed to put and it said so I have a
picture of that too it wasn't leotal
injection they were talking about gas
yes I don't even think I've ever heard a
gas chamber execution did you battle was
one of the last states
did you know what the gas entailed like
what like were you reading about it for
the first time like [ __ ] this is how I'm
gonna die yeah you know I was reading
about capsules and acid and but when do
you read about that like like you're on
death row and then you're like at what
point do you're like okay well I guess
well the guy that's up coming up which
was uh James Carroll you know I mean it
was real everybody was
when his time came up
and he didn't want to even uh finish the
appeals you know he said Let It Be
and uh it was just a real Eerie feeling
just that whole month you know watching
him watch how you move and you know his
conversation became very short you know
this was a a very reliable you know uh
interesting type of guy because he had a
lot of stories to tell you know old
gangster stories and so
[Music]
um
when they was preparing him for the
overnight sales
well you know well I got they pulled a
joke on me and it was like an initiation
because you you dealt with six officers
all the time
on death row so when I got there
uh I'll get back to those but when I got
there uh they ran you know they ran the
gamut down to me this is allowed you're
not going to be able to do this you're
on death row we're going to respect you
you know but this is our house you know
and they had no problem coming in a few
times they had to come in and let me
know you know I was
hello I was being lonely and you know
I'm in Carson City you know never been
around this much snow in the wintertime
and the cows are dumb they're standing
out in the snow and my window's facing
this Farm life and you know I'm just
watching reality just leave every day
reality leaves because this is all I
have is these people you know up here
right and I made the 12th person at that
time so uh one of the Jesus Freak up
there he said well you're the 12th
disciple
huh
okay let's let's break down the the time
he spent on death row I understand it
was three and a half years yes and then
you got your sentence commuted to life
without parole and how long were you in
prison facing life without parole after
two years 25 years after the death
penalty
so then 25 years and how to how does
life without parole turn into your free
well
um
I took the advice of a lot of smart
people
some of them have you know died and gone
on and some are out and they're living
productive lives you know but they gave
me a lot of advice man
um
one thing was to never give up on your
education
you know and I did once I got my GED and
a little high school diploma and did the
little graduation with the Clark County
School District uh I took some college
courses and tried to uh
least come out with an Associate but
I got disinterested once I got life with
the possibility of parole you know uh I
got eager now and I had to really look
at myself and go am I really for this
world because I it's like I was living a
make-believe world in here you know now
I'm going to be free as a man how far
into life without parole did it become
life with the possibility of pearl
um in 2003 the late Governor Kenny Quinn
May rest in peace
he looked at me and goes you look tired
he goes I'm I'm not an ex-cop I'm not an
ex-judge I'm not a lawmaker
I'm a businessman
and I think you'll be great
wow I think you'd be great one day in
society and you know who
echoed that the late Senator the late
great Senator Harry Reid I have a
picture with Senator he invited me to
Washington
and you heard about my story and uh he
sit and talked with my mom and he wrote
letters and things uh concerning my um
um eligibility Rehabilitation well yeah
well you know there's a such word as
habilitation
habilitation mean you knew something
before the rehabilitation okay if you
didn't if you don't know nothing before
you rehabilitate it well how are you
being rehabilitated all right I had to
learn things like that also but you know
uh Stevo it's been a it's been a great
experience man uh I achieved a lot of
accolades while I was in prison I was a
lot of Firsts I was the first to put a
band together
uh coming off a death row and they
didn't believe I can do it but I grew up
in this town so I started reaching out
to people and I was always musically
inclined you know so I reached out to
several of the outlets and they started
sending me used drums Used Guitars and
bass and pianos so I asked the director
if I find the inmates
that can play these instruments will you
allow us to have a band not only did
they allow us to have a band we traveled
from prison to prison wow
in this state
off of death row off of death yeah
that's not happening in death row right
I had wardens come in and they bring
their guitar and sit in with the jam
session wow it's just I have so many
firsts man you know like I said I'm so
proud even though my mom is in dementia
and we take care of her you know that
old lady is taking care of real well but
uh
I wanted her to see
the this part because she didn't she
don't know about the book she didn't you
know she don't know about me performing
and going out talking to the youth and
giving back like I do but uh she was my
biggest fan and sounds like it wow what
a lady man
when were you freed
I was freed in
2008 I walked out
2008. yeah what was the first thing you
did when you got freed I kissed the road
right in front of the parole you know
they dropped you off in front of the uh
parole office parole and probation
because you have to check in and get
your ID and stuff and uh my mom was
there
and uh I didn't even hug her I just got
off the van and they took the chains off
and
I lean down and kiss the ground
did you feel free
not at first
it felt like a bad move
yeah I mean when I you know ex-convicts
you know we have certain words that we
use when I say a bad move
um you're they're gonna move you from
one prison to the next maybe this prison
is better this prison yard so it's a bad
move better bed move and it's like I
know that I'm still under scrutiny and
and I'm up under a microscope and
someone still has authority over me
because I can't get visas I can't leave
the country
right yeah I understand that you have a
lifetime supervision while you're out
lifetime parole so what what does that
mean well for me the laws change and I
am what you consider up under past loss
and they still apply to me
yes so I can still apply for a
commutation of sentence or get my
sentence commuted or I can even ask for
a determined sentence like uh I could go
back to the district court and say hey
can I go for a citizen uh modification
and that judge may turn around and say
yeah I'll give you 10 years time sir now
I'm off parole and I can you know I
don't have to seek no one to try and um
own a weapon or anything like that and
on that note I don't care if I ever own
a gun again right give me a
beta
yeah
did you find it hard getting acclimated
back into society
yes I did because back in 2008 that's
like iPhones computers laptops yes yeah
you went back to the future they gave me
a flip phone and all it did was answer
my sister go all you have to do is just
open it up and when you're done close it
wow it should say that's it don't touch
nothing don't
wow I didn't know any numbers I didn't
know how I didn't know how to do
anything and thank God I wasn't around
for um the beepers and all that you guys
went yeah yeah what is the other one um
fax machine
um email yeah man it's just you know the
I.T part of this sometimes I can wake up
and it feels like I'm on bars somewhere
like right look at this out here man and
I'm you know do I deserve this you know
I beat myself up a lot because I
understand
uh the value of human life I understand
Humanity man and we all need each other
and no one has the right no one has that
right to take nobody's life
that's why I say when you get up
criminally insane person that don't care
yeah all right yeah well how do you know
if somebody's like just faking that
well you know
well let's say in the criminal world you
know when you got a bunch of convicts
guys that's on a prison yard
everybody's gonna find
their group
the strong are gonna sit back and just
look at everybody through the yard and
go he's an idiot you know he's gay he's
mentally ill and
believe it or not
on that
or that type of uh evaluation of people
nine times out of ten they're right you
know I mean
I don't doubt that and I would take it a
step further to say
that I believe in that prison structure
that life is a lot more
equal to what our DNA is built for it to
be like probably the the natural the
Primal like like early humans live by
that code more than what's going on in
this society that we have now yeah I
tell you what
this Society better wake up soon and the
people they better listen to
are the people that have done decades
in prison behind a wall in a shoe
program you know Pelican Bay here High
Desert Ely you know you bet if if these
people make it back to the streets and
they say I want to serve
you better listen because I'm telling
you I was telling lawmakers I go this
past summer
this summer coming you're going to see a
wave in these young kids these high
school kids
you know I'm talking to football players
a good team they're bringing guns to
practice so the coach says James can you
come talk wow and I'm talking to this
football team you know and these guys
are seniors and I go you you waited your
whole life to get to the next level the
money round
and you're here playing games
at a high school
you know and and it was just High School
After High School and now you know the
news can't report it fast enough you
know the carjackings are back you know
the home invasions are back and these
kids don't they don't care you know why
I watch the school district and I hate
it happen here because I love Vegas
Vegas is my town man I mean you know um
the school district here
I watched them graduate
six high schools of seniors
that are dumb as [ __ ]
hmm you know why I know
because I'm their Mentor these are kids
that they you send them to a behavior
school okay they do a couple of weeks
now you put them back on a regular
schoolyard
and
uh they're walking around they got
monitors ankle monitors because they're
facing charges whether it's down in
juvenile or down in adult you know and I
know these kids but you're going to give
them a diploma you're gonna let them do
the pump and Circumstance with a gown
and you're going to give them a diploma
when he he can't even tell you who the
governor is he can't even leave his mom
mom house and go and balance a checkbook
fill out an application
he's 18.
and they're you know they're all
together and they got their diplomas and
they're taking pictures I got it right
in my phone
these are graduations that I attended
and this is how America is not just here
so I'm not just gonna pounce on this
state but this is how America is and
they're releasing these kids
and these kids don't give a damn about
the jobs that our parents work uh the
type of money that's coming in they got
their own method of doing things their
own way and we're lucky enough that they
still respect guys like me I can walk it
doesn't matter where I go
you know uh I can walk in a room and go
can you guess this guy profession
you know quite natural I was I used to
be big real big so they
well I don't know he's a football player
he's a sports player oh he's a cop
everything but a criminal
everything
you know right I thought you were gonna
say you're not a musician it makes me
feel good though you know right okay uh
just to be out here and if I don't tell
you I've been on death row
right I'm just another black guy right
walking by let me ask you about the
difference between being on death row
and being in general population
well on death row you're dealing with
you know uh a sec select group of guys
and everybody got the same sentence so a
smaller number of guys yes and the
respect level is high
you know I mean except for you're trying
to you're thinking about killing the one
guy dude I'm dude I'm telling you got so
serious one day at wreck time I went out
to the pen and it just it had just
snowed right so
uh at old Max in Carson City the the
construction crew back then or somebody
but there was
Nails this long rusted Nails you know
and you can tell either it came out of
an old concrete slab or something but uh
it was left by a construction crew so I
got one and I you know and I got past
the tower and I
I buried it you know and every chance I
got I put a little sharpen on it you
know because I was going to kill this
dude
it took the only other black guy that
was on death row
in 1982 to stop me from killing my
neighbor
you know because it's on the news we're
watching this dude you know Reno news
how he did this girl and now he's on
death row with us you know right and he
got centers they gave him the death
penalty and you're not gonna live next
to me but it took the only other guy
that was on death row oh they got much
older than me you know and I we we sort
of knew each other from the county jail
you know we he was a badass nobody
messed with this dude so uh when he saw
that I got to definitely yeah I remember
you but I told him I said yeah I'm Gonna
Knock this dude off we'll do everybody a
favor
he say well
if you do that then you might as well go
on that chamber over there
you know
and he said you may not he may kill you
you underestimating him because he just
a little skinny squinty guy he's on
death row with you
what makes you better than him
the same society that said kill him
said kill you
and man that sin man that woke me up and
Believe It or Not Stevo I spoke to the
guy you know didn't want to know him and
I but every day I would amen you know
did you tell him you were thinking about
killing him no thank you
I mean he I think he literally totally
also I never want to be out with this
guy okay you know I'm the youngster and
the only other young stuff there they're
up there for killing um uh a detective
up in Reno that makes them like uh
royalty oh prison they got taken care of
yeah I mean the Aryan Brotherhood man I
I smoke weed whatever I wanted you know
that's what I want to talk about and the
officers you know the officers that was
on CMU condemned man unit that was up in
Carson City uh that's that throw that's
death row and they understood most of
them guys are dead I don't think one of
them is living because they were older
guys seasoned officers they knew how to
talk to you they you know the guy
bringing you a pie and say hey James my
wife made this WOW eat the whole pie
James you know some fish we went and
caught some you know some bad yes James
and my wife cooked it up eating you know
because we was there you know we didn't
go outside
we were on top of the fourth we're on
top of the sale house you know
and one of the greatest moments I got to
get this in Tom Selleck
did a movie on the yard an innocent man
and before he left he asked where's
death row and he turned around and
pointed at death row if I ever get a
chance to talk to Tom Selleck I said you
pointed at me dude wow and I say those
dudes that's in the movie those are my
homeboys train and all them nights them
dudes use playing basketball they're my
homeboys wow so they really did those
were not actors no no those were
convicts that's incredible yeah but Tom
Selleck he he I mean if you ever watched
that movie man he was he just fell in
place right and you know I might have to
watch that so when I went back and I did
a little tour of the prison you know
after almost 40 Years of
it's just a lot of memories came back
you know but he donated a lot of uh
weights and stuff like that to the yard
and he looked out for the yard Tom
Selleck man that's cool you said that
when you were in death throw that you
were watching the news with your
neighbor on death threat so you're
you're seeing about his case and that's
why you arrived at the conclusion that
you needed to take care of him
um to me it's fast I wasn't only one now
right it was other guys at that same
thing right to me it's fascinating that
you're on death row watching TV like
where's the TV located uh your family
was allowed to send you a package every
six months and they send you a stereo TV
back then you can man I I can have a 50
inch TV wow
I mean you know and I mean they're going
to take it apart and you yeah I remember
the Eddie Murphy movie uh 48 hours with
Nick Nolte and he had a TV in himself
yeah so yeah she got a TV in yourself on
death row
um and it can get can you get a cable
subscription or watch MTV and HBO and
the the
um the prison had a cable system that
they had to deal with and
um every cell you know they was paying
um like so much for so many sales so we
got the basic cable you know the sports
channel so you got ESPN skinny Max
see you never miss uh the Super Bowl no
you get all the regular channels you got
ESPN you got MTV yeah they knew they
knew what it what it took to keep a
maximum
you know
prison or institution calm right when
you when you let uh inmates and convicts
watch TV and have another Escape you
know your yard is going to go pretty
well okay and like I said they gave me a
huge Outlet because
once the count was clear you know this
way after death row but I'm going
straight to the band room you know right
yeah I'm going straight to the gym to
the band room and how much time in death
row is spent um in yourself
it depends on your level of uh
classification right if you're being
good and you're not being a problem and
you're not receiving receiving like uh
notice of charges discipline you know
you have to go in front of a discipline
committee
um
you can spend up to almost 12 13 hours
out yourself and that uh 12 13 hours is
in like a communal yeah yeah you can you
can pick another guy to come out you can
play cards and normally uh me and the
other black guy that was on there he'd
come out and and he made Porter because
he went up another level so he was able
to go everywhere you know okay go get
the food and you know not outside but
they'll bring it to the big door and he
was able to grab it and bring up the
child and stuff what about drugs yeah
that's my next question are you smoking
weed on death row yeah I mean you know
you have to roll uh
a pinhead no bigger than a match you
know you know and so you roll it yeah
you know and so
um we had one officer even gave us the
uh the tip on how to get rid of the
smell
he said listen guys I ain't looking for
nothing
but I have a nose right so you take the
toilet roll you put the bounce sheet in
it yeah no that's the old that's that's
County Jail okay that's rookie stuff
okay
that's as high as Steve got
candidly I didn't even learn that trick
in jail I learned that in college dorms
which is amazing because it's just about
the only thing I learned in college but
I digress since College I've learned
something way more important which is
that Bluetooth tablets make sex a lot
more fun why because they contain the
same active ingredient as Viagra and
Cialis but they only cost a fraction of
the price that's right I'm talking about
Bluetooth tablets and man they're more
delicious now there's like a new flavor
or something I love the way they taste
and I love that when I chew them up and
then I go show my girl my blue tongue
she screams and hugs me and she knows
I'm gonna take her to Bone Town that's
right the Boneyard because Bluetooth
tablets give me a major boner ah man so
much fun if you're really still
wondering our Bluetooth tablet's fun I
can assure you they are plus you could
get an entire month's supply of
Bluetooth tablets completely for free
all you got to pay is five bucks for
shipping if you go to bluetooth.com and
use the promo code Stevo that's right
plus the prescription you consult with
an online provider a medical provider
online at bluetooth.com you take care of
that quickly and easy and again an
entire month's supply of Bluetooth
tablets it's on its way to your house
and you are having a good old time all
you got to pay is five bucks for
shipping so jump on this deal go to
bluetooth.com use the promo code Stevo
and let's get back to it
uh but on death row we were allowed to
have like uh Skillets and hot plates and
things like that right because you know
it was like a privilege the warden say
loans you guys like that's their
incentive to keep everything running
smooth exactly and so uh we had a guy I
just called him by the name of moose Old
biker and he's on death row and he would
love to get up and cook eggs and uh
Short Line was a bunch of all uh lifers
and they had a garden so they were sent
up fresh stuff to the death row what's
Short Line Short Line uh lifers who are
never getting out but they have a trade
and they they're giving back some type
of way of the license plate Factory yep
you know uh maintenance the old Boiler
Room those are lifers that live in there
and that's that's like a privilege to
live in The Boiler Room you got this big
old room and you don't have no body no
no officer breathing down you you got a
courtyard you can come out to you just
taking care of the Boiler Room make sure
you know and so I never made Shortline
because of the death row status once I
got off of death row but um
they looked out for death row and sent
us fresh uh garden and fruits and
vegetables up there and he would cook
and we you know and some of the harder
drugs too you know I wasn't it you know
but the tip to getting rid of the smell
the officer would bring us popcorn
and you just simply burned that bag of
popcorn until you can't burn it no more
you put it on high and like what the
hell it's you you ever smell burnt
popcorn sure it's good you ain't gonna
smell the weed okay so and you know we
were getting weed like from Humboldt
County up in Winnemucca this is the
great greater weed coming down from yeah
so the white guys they you know they
really looked out man and the
Brotherhood was one thing you know as
long as the drug flow was cool
everybody's cool and that that's from
Death Row to the general population
that's in every prison Across America as
long as that drug flow is cool there's
no racial tensions there's no
Uprising against the administration
everybody's you know self-medicated
doing their own doing that right how
about alcohol are you are you making
your own alcohol on death row well
Pruno that's still rookie stuff okay
veterans you drinking alcohol you're
bringing them Seagrams as long as
they're as long as they're a free staff
and what I mean by a free step a free
citizen whether it's a nurse a store
keeper a bookkeeper that's other than
anything other than an officer that's
been sworn by you know they're they're
going to bring in they can be
compromised okay I mean even officers I
gotta believe are gonna participate too
sure you know once you have a family
member you can be a 20 year old cop you
know and and declarated once you have a
family member that went through the
justice system and you love that family
member your heart
turns a little bit right if you I've
seen so many correction officers more
men than women often to you know dude I
understand man I was this far from being
here right you know what you need man
you good you know right you know and you
learn to respect okay this guy's just
trying to go home he could have been
here but he chose this life and then he
offered me something you know he's he's
coming you know
with a gift like dude I'm not just
talking uh I know you got life you're in
a shoe program you know no one may ever
untie that shoe you know and that's just
the lingo for being locked away right
what a shoe means if you put your shoe
on yeah his shoe is on that shoe is
going to stay on until what so take it
off so if you put a man in a cell and
you lock that door he's in there that's
a shoe program that's like 23 hours a
day that's right so so when you got off
that throw were you in the shoe
I was in uh intensive
um
what was they calling it uh attentive
group where you they modified you you
had to check in you know because I was
different so they had to check my
my psych you know being on death row and
being young so they really monitored me
I had to go and see the psychologists
um once a week we sit there and she and
I would talk the same thing yeah we
think about life James well
uh
I'm I'm alive that's what I think about
life you know I live the rest of my life
you know in here she said that may just
happen but what if you're free one day
you know and she's dead now too but all
those old people but anyway that was a
normal day you know just being um
being locked away man and I tell you
what
um
until
a man
is faced with
being you have to live with another
person that you don't know this is a
stranger you just moved in he's a lifer
like you
and
is he strong like me is you know you
don't know this person and so and the
worst thing that the prison system did
to me
when they allowed
the race you can't mix races
they should have never done that when
did they do that
in this state I think it was 86 they
started pushing the classification
changed and in prison you know the only
people that can live together if you
come in and say you know uh you're gay
and you rather live with a gay person
blah blah blah but just uh me and you
bunking up at Sellers no the
administration oh no
because they're no they know that soon
as the drugs get low or soonest
somebody get hit that shouldn't have got
hit you know a stabbing or something
went on
um
the forces that be are going to change
and uh you can't live with that black
guy anymore
you're either a soldier you're either
with us or you're not and the same with
the blacks you can't live with that
white guy why are you living with him
and the guy goes we went to school
together our families know each other
I'm from same neighborhood with this guy
we don't care yeah this is the code you
don't know about it could I ask
what was your last meal gonna be
I'm sorry well you know what uh I'm glad
you mentioned it because they played a
trick on me when I got there
two of the officer old silver fox
and um
oh um
Woodman
came and got me and they said youngster
we just got a call from the courts we're
gonna have to prepare you in the
overnight still
you know meaning
your time's up yeah everybody's quiet on
the road I'm I'm looking for the you
know for killer the black guy to go
you know give me a sign or something
what you know and he's not up he's not a
bit at his bars looking at me and you
know he's
so they get me and they take me over and
the priests come up father Dave good guy
I forgave him he's part of the he's well
Mr Allen um we know that you're a
Christian he's reading from it and you
know he was raised a Christian blah blah
blah would you like to say a prayer and
everything and I'm looking at
are you is this real
you know I mean I'm right across from
the chamber and you know they got two
cells you got the overnight sales then
you got the chamber and I'm looking
are they serious
so they left me in there to like one
o'clock
in the morning that night you know they
came and got me like five that afternoon
you know like one o'clock and uh Silver
Fox go come on out youngster
we just wanted to see your man who want
to see if you you know if you pumping
that that real blood when you're gonna
break down
and I'm you know and so killer comes out
and he really embraced me he said man
don't think nothing of that you know we
got the other youngsters when they came
up here the ones that knocked off the uh
the detective you passed the test yeah
you passed the test so you know don't
think but I had to tell my mom and she
was Furious they did what and she uh she
raised she called The Lieutenant she had
a way of reaching and getting hold of
people you know and next thing you know
here come these wardens and you know you
okay youngster you're all right you know
and they have me talk to the
psychologist and you know I'm good
that's some like fraternity Haze and
yeah so I had to put that in the book
man and I forget those officers because
it shook me but it you know it something
deep down and said no it ain't happening
like this Mr Criminal didn't say it's
going to happen like this you know I got
a stay of execution and I got so I
started thinking you know right when you
got from off death row into regular
prison did you miss death row at all
sure you know I I developed some good
friendship in there you know it's some
guys uh they still on the road after all
these years and I would love to see them
make it off and just live a life you
know um
um Tom Wilson he's the longest one up
there now you know
I like to see Tom and you know and uh
murder is murder man uh you know there's
to me there's
there's no way to really Define uh
you know a killing
if it's in if it's an intent you know
you have sit and you've contemplated
killing somebody and you've mapped out
how it's gonna go
yeah you know yeah
you don't deserve this this type of life
this this life now is fun man you know
uh when I made it home
and I you know I used to sit back and go
wow this is what I was in a hurry to
come back to you know because I'm
watching the news and you're watching
all this bad stuff and you're watching
and I'm going wow man but
in my life I have to calculate my life
and where I'm at with my family and my
loved ones in the circle that you know
and and it's okay I'm in I'm in a good
place
um you know
I have a Bible
and it's in my truck right now there's a
picture of my Victim in the back of my
Bible
so every morning when I say a prayer I
say a prayer for Mr Sylvester too
you know he was a good dude man you know
I learned a little about my Victim and
you know nice home and he's you know he
had a fiance he was getting ready to get
married you know uh what I say if he had
the chance to say something today I
think he probably would say
give Mr Allen a chance
you know because I have a good heart and
I made some good good conscious changes
about me I did some sold searching man
and did you ever reach out to his family
after you got free well no that was one
of the Clauses okay do not try and
contact because they knew me the prison
officials and the parole Commissioners
by now they know James Allen's going to
try and find out what his heart is you
know I love everybody and if I can help
everybody I want to right
um one of the things I want to do uh
the outgoing governor of this state
Governor sisterlock
put a put a motion on the floor about a
week ago to abolish the death penalty
and his constituents rose up against him
so I was there and he came over a week
ago as in from today yeah yeah at the
Supreme Court building they hold the uh
they held the annual party board session
so would it be in his last hearing uh he
placed the motion on the floor to
abolish the death penalty but uh I don't
think that committee had that power so
many other things had to take place
before but I commend him for doing that
and in that uh I would love for this
state
to allow me
to go and talk to those men and let them
know
hey you may not get the opportunity that
I got
but if they abolish the death penalty
and they give you life
man makes the best make the best of it
those guys of you those guys of you that
are on death row you're smart you're
Educators you know you were smart and
growing up and things because I know
them you know they I mean it's some guys
real quick come out and help these
younger guys that's on the yard that
will make parole
I would love to have that opportunity to
talk to death row you said that when you
got off death row and in regular prison
that you missed the friendships that you
had on death row yeah but did you miss
the the quality of life like what was
the quality of life in regular prison
compared to to death row this is
something I really wanted to know about
the quality of life in prison versus on
death row but first let me tell you
about the quality of life if you're in
therapy or if you're not because this
episode's brought to you by better help
and spoiler alert quality of life is a
lot better if you're in therapy and
actually
speaking up about the things that are
bothering you and figuring out ways to
address them and there's no better way
to do that than with
betterhelp.com that's better h-e-l-p
dot com and if you go to betterhelp.com
Stevo you get 10 off your first month
now a first month of what it's therapy
that teams you up with the ideal
therapist for you based on what it is
you want help with and they've teamed up
over three million people with
therapists and these sessions can happen
online you don't have to go driving
around anywhere it's super simple super
affordable plus again you get 10 off
your first month if you go to
betterhelp.com Stevo again my quality of
life is a lot better because I use
therapy to speak up about what's going
on about what's bothering me and
figuring out how to address it so I urge
you to increase your Quality of Life by
going to betterhelp.com
now let's compare death row to prison
did you bring your television set from
yourself same TV and you got to set up
the same TV and if I was smart if I was
a smart man
I would have took all of that stuff that
my family sent to me on death row boxed
it up and sent it home it'd be worth
some money today wow but I got an ID
card I still have mine okay so so you
take all of it you take all this stuff
in your death row cell the TV everything
and you move it right into your uh to
your prison cell is the prison cell the
same size as the death or herself death
row was plush wow that's what we're
trying to figure out you know I mean a
death row cell was like big as your you
know your your RV here yes wow yes yeah
we got one roommate in the death row so
no Roommate by yourself
um one thing about death row you're not
gonna have a roommate okay no that
that's one thing a state's not going to
do no stayed in America
so so now you move into regular prison
you do have a roommate yes and you're
thinking man get me back on death throw
this sucks what you know the first time
I hit a medium yard I thought I was
literally on a college campus
these guys are wearing jordish jeans
they're wearing silk shirts long as blue
they were in low float you know show
floaters and uh they wearing low quarter
shoes and hats and and they're headed to
visiting I'm going they're going to
visiting like you know and I got
pictures of me on death row you know
when I had my Afro and my mom come up
you know I got pictures and so I'm used
to just wearing jeans I get there and
I'm looking you know and I tell you man
literally
I see these women
and you know guys are coming up to me
they glass they're hugging me you know
James Allen you're off death row we're
glad Papa so
I see a flock of women over here right
and I'm looking
women inmates or women visitors I I'm
thinking these are women
these are not women oh they're not oh
god
listen dude
booty shorts and I'm looking like and
and one guy go now those are not women
there there's a lot more freedom of
expression in prison compared to death
back then right back then now
death row I think death row is just
they're just there man they're just
sitting there all of the programs have
been stripped prison is nothing like it
was am I am I calling that right prison
versus because death row is prison yes
it's all the same none of it's the same
okay so so what what would I call it you
went from Death Row to general
population okay
um and in general population is there
more or less drugs and alcohol oh dude
and see I came you know my error was
you can have currency on the yard
dude it was dudes rolling quarters and
taping them up as long as this bar here
you know and would go to the store with
you know
how many however much that was you know
you'd get a pen and write it on there if
that's 60 bucks if that's it's like
about 60 bucks worth of quarters you go
to the store
and uh the store keeper he looking okay
he knows you know and I'm telling you
man it was nothing to walk around with a
thousand dollars of uh paper money that
was illegal you only can have the
quarters you know you could only can
have uh you know in currency but you
couldn't have paper dollars and man when
people had it anyway poker game Big Time
poker games guys betting two and three
hundred dollars
wow yeah so some more money more drugs
more alcohol in general population and
guess what this was doing the what the
Democrats in charge and the Republicans
it didn't matter you know prison had a
standard where it took care of himself
you know there was prison jobs there was
prison furloughs so in the 80s and the
90s you know if you had to do some time
you can walk I mean one of my first jobs
I was making minimum wage I was working
for
um Imperial Palace
uh classic car collection they would
bring out one car and we would strip it
down and it was paying us minimum wage I
was sitting home literally six to seven
hundred dollars a month and that was
huge sending it to your mom yeah you
know to take care of my kids yeah I had
my my son when I got arrested my son was
one years old and my daughter just
turned uh she was like five months wow
okay so they grew up I got a picture of
me and my son and my daughter uh
standing in the visiting room and like I
said my son came and you know that was
an experience there man uh I tell you
yeah that's a that's a big part of your
story is that you're in general
population your son's 15 years old and
you're sharing a cell in prison with
your son yeah unfortunately he he was
part of a program
where uh they was targeting young youth
who were at risk and my son had a
fascination of guns too so what he he
takes
the handle the butt of a 32 and he's got
it sitting in his locker so when kids
see it all they're seeing is the handle
you know the butt of the gun right right
so the judge figured well
we're gonna put you on this 90-day uh
program we're gonna you're gonna go out
to the prison and you're gonna be around
convicts convicted felons and they're
going to Mentor you you're going to be
there for 90 days it's like a serious
high level Scared Straight program and
so I really wasn't in contact with his
mom at the time that side of the family
so this is how it stuck up on me but God
came to the band room one day and he
goes hey it's a kid down in intake said
he's your kid
Sandy's my kid
so I
uh summoned award and I go I need to go
to intake I need to go down there Ward
and you know the warden had a lot of
trust in me by this time I can pretty
much move around the institution
so I go down and I look at this kid and
it's my kid
I mean what are you doing and he go pops
I'm here for 90 days so
that next morning I went to the warden's
office I said you have to move I know
it's against the I know I'm working the
program because I had several youngsters
before and he goes you know we can't do
that Alan I go please put him in the
room with me he needs to learn something
I may not ever get a chance to be a
father wow I may not ever get a chance
to teach him nothing man and I'm telling
the warden goes he made me sign the
agreement and my son had to sign it and
the waivers and we moved my son in
and uh
this kid man he really didn't know
nothing he know how to brush his teeth
he didn't know how to
shower and keep his hygiene up in one of
the most uh dramatic and profound
moments of my incarceration was the
night they came
and told him and I to step out the room
and strip down and I'm standing there
naked in front of my son
wow and he's Nick and I go that's what
you want
that's what you want
take a take a lesson you know why'd they
do that because they well when they're
doing a strip search you know they can
pick any sale and go to any unit and it
can be
um just random but uh I think they was
you know I had I had a couple run-ins
with a couple officers and I think they
was trying to get back and embarrass me
in front of my my kid so we're standing
there and they didn't you know after
they tore up the sale and went through
everything and we went back in and I go
well get dressed and now let's put the
sale back like it's supposed to look
real comfortable and let's watch some TV
there you go let's get back to the
football game yeah but you know it was a
pleasure man being a dad and my son even
though he didn't learn from that lesson
my son did 25 years in Arizona he's been
recently released he's doing well he's a
manager
um uh for some phone company some type
of uh
he's doing well and he got married and
uh he wrote a little book a little
memoir book you know about being in
prison and being around his dad uh he's
not talented but he can play drums he
can't sing or anything you know I can
sing and play just about every
instrument so
um
I'm really interested by how you said
they they you got people to send a piano
into a prison keyboards all kind of
synthesizers man so now some of the
stuff we had to fix and we were allowed
to go in the maintenance shop and use
soldering guns and you know we had to
take some of the resistors and tweak
with them and you know get some of the
old tube amps and recharge them but um
and uh the the piano is not going to
live in your cell next to your 50-inch
TV it's going to go to the band room yes
but there was no band room before you
and guys were allowed I mean it depends
on like I said your classification the
level that in what prison you're you're
on and some guys were allowed to have a
guitar in their cell a small keyboard
um you know
um and you of course you have to have
headphones you know a little mini amp
you know as time you know went by and
Technology yeah but and you had all the
same TV channels and general population
as you did on death row yes same
everybody no more no less no more no
less and Well on death row if there's
certain uh programming that they didn't
want us to watch like uh no kid stuff
yeah they blocked they would block it
out okay
um
serial killers type you know you you
weren't gonna watch did you ever see the
the show on a e called The First 48 yeah
that show's good
I love that show so you're able to watch
that in jail when when uh when the when
our Jackass movie came out did you see
that in jail you know
um I heard of it and
I don't know I it was something that
someone was saying that it's a bunch of
guys and they're playing grab ass and
they're just yeah
that doesn't sound like
but I'll tell you the first episode that
I really watched was uh jackass forever
okay wow yeah that was even more grab
ass than usual yeah
I'm watching the dragon and I had no
clue what the dragon was and my
brother's sitting there watching it with
me there's a dragon
going through the town
[Music]
my other favorite is the wee man yeah we
man he's great wow right you know what
and I'm telling my you know a couple
people they know about you guys and
they're going man
dude you gonna be with Stevo and and I
go well you know they found out about
the story and you know I mean it's a
hell of a story man yeah it's a hell of
a story wait and I'm really just I'm
fascinated by the the whole
just idea of of prison and what what
it's like it's really interesting to
hear you describe it and
I feel like you're describing
uh a quality of life which
you know I'm not gonna say that being in
prison doesn't sound so bad
but at the same time
you got
you got a life in there you got a life
in prison and it helps me understand
yeah some of the things I was telling
you it helps me to understand why people
would would really want to take death
penalty off the table because in prison
it's not great to be in prison but you
got a life in there yes I tell you what
Steve uh I told you at the beginning I
felt like I was a
a guinea pig or a part of a test uh type
of
uh program you know where people wanted
me to fail out here I couldn't adapt uh
I was so far behind time and being on
death row reality and there's there's a
lot of pressure on me to always
um
go beyond you know
um
I don't want to be out here and be
um stuck as they say you know I want to
learn just as fast as the next guy I
want to you know I want to be competing
just like the next guy I want to be
right there and uh help my family and
um be a servant
that's what I am I'm a servant now you
know they gave me time to serve and
by all means I guess
the time served itself and All Is
Forgiven and now I'm a servant out here
I'm always be a servant even after death
row you know I don't think no one has
this story in nowhere in the world
um
and that have done the things that I
have been allowed to do and I'm very
very appreciative and I'm very
remorseful that a person lost their life
behind my ignorance and my silliness
that I deserved it definitely
no
and I tell you why but I deserved a
punishment
I deserved a lifetime punishment
to serve
you know I have to give back and a lot
of doors are closed a lot of doors are
not being opened because people know
it's a fascinated story and I think this
is the first time that it's actually
probably on a national level you know
with you guys everything's always been
local it's like they want to keep it and
it's not going to stay that way not with
you know I mean I'm I'm just now
understanding this right you know I mean
this this this was a monster to me I bet
you know what what
when you were in prison did you watch
the movie The Green Mile yes so that now
did you watch that in your cell
yes so that means you had VCR or a DVD
player too yeah well what they would do
is uh every week a unit would be graded
on cleanliness uh how well you behave
and they would bring in a movie and you
you could pick the movie they bring out
a list and uh during that time Green
Mile was at the top of the boxing yeah
man we won't see Green Mountain it's a
good movie oh great movie and and when
you Shawshank Redemption oh Shawshank
Redemption maybe the other one I was
thinking of
um
when uh when you asked Vinnie over here
asked you if you had trouble acclimating
to freedom because of technology I was
thinking forget about the technology
about work what about just being
institutionalized there's that guy in
The Shawshank Redemption who's just too
institutionalized I wanted to go back in
couldn't deal with it he killed himself
because he couldn't deal with it yeah
did you relate with that guy on any
level well you know I understood what he
went through because when you're back in
those days in that type of structure and
yeah and the way they was portraying
that sale house a dungeon yes Brooks you
know that's all he had and he'd befriend
a bird yeah you know reality is gone if
you're gonna talk to
right so here I know guys personally
they can't adapt
and they've only done like maybe 10 15
years and they're just struggling and
they go how do you do it Mr Allen you
know and I go and that's that's every
race you know yeah I mean that's just
Humanity I am president of the lifers
group which uh the former director first
woman director of state of Nevada she
allowed us to form that group and they
respected it's on the books today the
lifers group and so I've been trying to
the lifers that are out here on parole
and they're on Lifetime parole like me
but they have businesses they're
upstanding citizens right their
neighbors don't never knew that this guy
I've been eating at this guy's
restaurant and he's an ex-felon and he
did 20 years but these are the type of
guys that I'm telling get out here let
the people know that you're out here you
know right now was it difficult for you
finding paying work right when you got
to fill out that I'm a felon well I'll
tell you what when I my first job was at
a place called Anderson Dairy and I was
uh loading trucks at night you know milk
and dairy coal as hell and I had a crew
I was with a crew of of uh Mexicans and
none of them spoke English and you know
but it showed me something different
that in prison
you can't break bread together
but out here these guys can barely you
know they just knew I was a crew member
they didn't care if I was a hex felon
you know and they gave me a burrito like
at lunch time you know but the job was
very easy to get uh because
I would go in and I'll tell them hey I'm
fresh out of prison you know can I work
here do you guys hire ex-felons I'm just
telling you up front and they go fill
out the application so that was a sign
right there right it's a case-by-case
for sure yeah all right so yeah and
right today
um you know I have like a sciatic
arthritis coming on or something but I
get that pinched nerve so I can't do a
lot of physical work but and I don't
like
um
a lot of
I don't know software you know I'm I'm a
man and I've worked with my hands and
you know
um don't you make a living in with your
band well you know I'm trying to get a
residency here
um and I'm grateful that you know uh
places like the Sand Dollar
um I did corporate gigs out on the strip
I you know uh some of the strip hotels
but they not a residency you know and I
don't know if it's because of the
ex-felon but I I'm a business I'm a
business license and I'm insured I'm but
the band is and we're pretty good band
what's the band name it's James Allen in
unique Minds James Allen and unique
Minds unique mind are you just vocals or
do you play instruments here well uh in
this band I'm doing most of the uh lead
singing and percussions okay
and uh is your music available to people
to find on well what we do yeah we're on
YouTube and uh we do a lot of uh cover
tunes okay so you know we want you
dancing in the lounge and then but
um I'm really trying to get the band
somewhere and it's a little because you
know if I'm allowed to go on the road
and tell my story I would like to bring
my band along sure I would like for a
producer or a director to go well we
hear that uh you're a singer uh will you
do a song for us and I'm you know we'll
put some musicians around you whatever I
got a band right we're able to record
music while you're in prison no no
recording device and if we one time we
tried and then they go and they found it
right and we had it going through one of
the Yamaha systems through the PA system
and you know we had a little you know
the little the old little box tape uh
cassette recorder yeah you know you can
hit play and you record it so we added
past in and they found out about it so
we had
did you get uh Tangled Up and and uh
engaged like you kind of have to be in a
gang in prison right oh you know what
let me take that back at the end right
before I paroled we did record cool I
did record with that band so they do
have that okay all right
um I mean we could probably talk forever
about but but in prison you kind of have
to be in a gang is that right oh you
have to show your type of uh Allegiance
you know you affiliate uh you associate
it you know I never
uh took on a tag of uh me being
initiated in I'm too strong for that I'm
a leader you know
um but my Association was through
um just friendship you know giving them
you know because I helped every game
once uh if you came out of [ __ ] out of
the fish tank intake you know and I you
know your your foul is going to tell me
what you are because you're coming from
the county jail so you're already tagged
and I know what you are and I you know
some of my spills doing um
um my intake uh portion
of orientation
I would tell the guys
if you come in here
because your homeboys on the yard
you made a mistake
because your homeboy is nothing
because if he was he'd be here
talking to you instead of me
so I would get the attention right away
you know and I would let them know the
chapel is off limits you don't go up
there sagging your pants you don't go up
there repping your game you don't go up
there beefing with no one you know the
chapel is a sacred Place uh Native
American
um they're uh lodges and stuff they're
they're space all that is sacred ground
so all that stuff had to be told to
these youngsters coming in because they
was coming in by the boatload and I mean
every nationality you know so what I'm
hearing is that you were diffusing a
whole lot yeah yeah and and did you find
yourself
like pressured into like situations that
you couldn't control which required you
to
put people in check to participate in
violence I'll tell you what dude
sometimes you know what
um
when you
when a convict knows that there's a a
window
or there's a little light at the end of
the tunnel
man he does a lot of soul searching and
I'm telling there's a lot of fights and
a lot of violence that I had to walk
away from you know and
when you got a guy calling you you know
another guy that thinks he's just tough
or he's trying to get a rep you know hey
I knocked off James Allen or I did this
to James Allen and blah blah blah but
you know you have to
you have to put yourself almost in a in
an acting position like I'm ready at all
time I may not look ready
yeah I'm ready at all times and if you
bring it I'm gonna bring it so and
that's how you have to carry yourself in
there man um you can't show no sign of
weakness after you show a sign of
weakness
they're gonna tell they may not get you
but it's gonna go down the pipe yeah got
one coming your way bam you know for all
my tough talk and I'm crazy and I do
stunts man I would not do well in there
I'll tell you what uh one of the
scariest moments was
uh black kid got killed
and he was from a rival game so all the
OG's got together and this is black and
white uh white guy killed a black guy
over a poker game the black guy jumped
on the white guy gave him a black eye
the white guy sitting there at the
next morning that the breakfast table
with a huge signer so his homeboys what
the hell happened to you
oh he whooped your you know so now
they're edging it on oh no you got to go
back you got to retaliate so now
one of the most scariest things is that
you don't know when it's going to jump
off so now you have to start preparing
yourself dude we have to literally go in
the law library and you can check out
four books at a time these big law you
know law books with the hardback binder
and I mean literally you have to line
your jacket oh wow that ain't that that
ain't nothing on the movie that's real
and I can literally you we have to go up
at old Max you have to go down these
steps and go through this tunnel
you know to get to the child Hall to get
to the kitchen and at the end of the
tunnel there's an officer with a spray
gun you do any type of wrong doing down
this tunnel he's gonna start spraying he
don't care what he hit like a fire hose
yes no bullets oh spray guns back then
it was buck shots
man I can look I got that dude would
start spraying somebody's getting to a
fight in that in their tunnel and he'll
start spraying them buck shots and you
can literally him just you can feel him
hitting your ankle you know we trying to
dive and get Run for Cover but I can
literally feel
and and you snubbed up against you know
every race it ain't the blacks over here
going through the tunnel everybody have
to go through the tunnel at one time and
you can feel somebody trying to hit you
dude
and I I got you I got a scrape right
here
got past the book and you don't know who
hit you you're looking around and you
know you ready to get into it but if you
start the fight you're gonna get shot
too because you're going through this
tunnel and you're you know
and I'm telling you that is serious you
know stuff like that I wanted to put in
the book because it's real but
uh you know it's just so many uh prison
stories man uh you know when you sitting
in the child Hall and you watch a guy
get hit in the neck and here's blood
just skeeting out and you know you up
under the table trying to keep from
getting shot and and see granted Steve
when I came off of death they still had
metal trays you got a metal fork and a
tray with a metal cup and I've seen
dudes get whooped so bad in that kitchen
with them
this is a weapon man that's working the
neck could do it these trades I mean you
can hit that it ain't gonna Bend it's a
tray you know County Jail yeah
I mean weapons Man
weapons I mean it's nothing that I gloat
about because I I I I I uh I welcome
that experience but I don't
enjoy how it came about because this
person lost their life
um but the experience
man
um I mean you've lived you've lived it
all man yeah to be 63
uh and to still be around I know a lot
of guys they're gone
that I did time that did 20 years make
it home and then die out here like they
couldn't get with this they couldn't
they couldn't gravitate to the you know
okay we're not in prison anymore it's
real right you know that James that you
knew in prison
totally different out here right you
know because you don't really know me
you met me in prison yeah we walked in
yards we talked stories we broke bread
but now I'm free see and so I don't know
Steve-O the Killer
you know do he really like me you know
then I have to go back what type of case
did he have how did he get that murder
you know because you don't know who
you're dealing with you're rubbing
elbows you're out here kicking it with
them you know like I said I'm out here
with lifers and stuff so this is why I
had to form the lifers group out here so
we can continue to stay in touch with
each other and see where we're at you
know a lot of them died off I'll tell
you man
hitting that dope yeah that you know
they they couldn't wait to get out and
get to that that real dope right so it's
safe to say that you very much value
your freedom oh yes sir yes sir oh I I
think I'm gonna live past 100 man God's
Gonna punish me you're gonna see this
all right you're gonna see this to the
end and it's just something he wants me
to see and you know I'm not a big Bible
thumping type of guy uh I do believe in
Christianity and I do believe that God
shined on me right that for whatever
reason he gave me this because uh
technically
the jury spoke
and the governor spoke
right gave your life you took you from
death row to life and now parole see so
it's something in the cards I just you
know right still trying to figure it out
and you're out here
giving back going to talk to people to
help them have better lives yes and
doing the right thing not breaking the
laws being a good guy yes sir all right
you know um
I wanted you to
I wanted to show you a little piece of
the band all right
can you hold up your book for the camera
so everybody can see just give it a plug
sure yeah they can get it on Amazon
right yes
yes and she's a great author and we
co-wrote the book together uh you know I
wasn't the first guy that she wrote
about the first guy that she wrote about
was this Cuban that was on death row
with me and uh he was convicted wrongly
he was the only guy I can actually say
that didn't do them that didn't do the
murder did you ever say you were
innocent when you were in prison no no
and that's rare yeah no no I'm guilty
yeah but it is in prison just full of
guys saying they didn't do it yes all
the time
all the time I mean you know
um
that's a standard uh and then literally
you get guys their first night in the
fish tank crying for their moms and boo
on like how did I do this how did I get
it you know these and these guys come
from a good home good upbringing and you
know Mom and Dad there and you know
schooling and everything but somewhere
along the lake you somewhere along the
way you fell off and you fell into this
this crime spree that's going on and now
you're part of the system man right yeah
all right man well let's let's see and
see the band thing yeah and uh you know
Mike Tyson said this to me when I was on
his podcast he said we got millions of
people watching right now what do you
want to say to them
and I like that you got a message for
everybody out there sure uh
uh
see that's what I'm saying man I've been
dealing with this same phone and when
you're trying to do something it's like
okay I'm not gonna do that it's all good
man
um there's a assemblyman here
um I I like giving respect to the
politicians that played a hand
and my freedom and one is
the formal assemblyman uh Harvey Mumford
who just had a name uh they just named
the street in his honor on his son is
where he left so that was but uh
Lawrence weekly you know he was a former
County Commissioner Senator Harry Reid
you saw the picture yeah and I think I'm
the only guy didn't come off a death row
with Harry Reid with his arm around him
you know they just named the airport
after him you know all right so
um
but
my message
is is one that's that's um
that's real simple
love life
live life
don't cheat life
all right
a message of gratitude man thank you
James thank you Steve Oak for having me
appreciate it yeah I thought that was
really cool man
yeah dude how about that I mean we put
up that no guest podcast which probably
some of you haven't seen because YouTube
age restricted it sheesh so click here
if you're on YouTube to check that one
out that's where we came up with the
idea to try to get a death row inmate to
interview and how about that it took
less than a week so get uh James Allen
Jr's book in the uh video description
right like uh we got we linked that
there and thank you guys so much I love
you